[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it
is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate
and practical answers to all your bible
questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive
any of the bible resources mentioned in
this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor doug batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
martin strill from slovenia is certainly
the world's greatest marathon swimmer
having swung down five of the planet's
mightiest rivers
the yangtze piranha mississippi
danube and amazon he holds four
guinness world records in long distance
open water swimming
during his adventures he's been attacked
by piranhas
struck by lightning and sickened by
polluted water
strel took on the mighty amazon river in
swimming the entire length of the river
from the headwaters in peru
to the brazilian port city of belim a
total
of 3 273 miles in 66
days that represents the distance
greater
than the width of the atlantic ocean did
you know the bible talks about a prophet
that survived underwater for three days
stay with us friends we're going to
learn more
on this edition of bible answers live
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
[Music]
welcome listening friends to bible
answers live and as you've heard if you
have bible questions
we'll do our best to answer them just
give a call 800-463-7297
that's 800 god says that's the acronym
for it
800-463-7297 with your bible questions
great chance you'll get your question on
tonight's program lines are wide open
right now
and we are live you can not only listen
here on this radio station but you can
watch
on our facebook page if you want to see
what's going on here in the studio
that would be the doug batchelor
facebook page or the amazing facts
facebook page and i am doug batchelor my
name is john ross good evening friends
and
as we always do let's start with the
program with prayer dear father we thank
you that we're able to open up your word
and study together
such a wonderful opportunity for us to
just do this
international bible study and get into
your word so lord we pray for your
blessing pray for your spirit to guide
in jesus name amen amen i'll pass it out
you know
just before we we went on the air we
were speaking about the incredible feats
of uh
this person i'll forget his name martin
strell yeah martin stroud who not only
swam
some of these great rivers but you
mentioned that he also swam
from africa to italy so he swam across
the mediterranean
that alone would be an incredible feat
let alone all these other rivers that is
oh yeah and he swam the rivers in
slovenia he swam
the colorado and the guy's just a
machine he
and he you know look at him he's a he's
a pretty uh
robust athlete i think now he's about 66
years of age but uh
yeah he just loved to swim and the story
is that when he was young
his father was pretty rough on him and
he'd come home from work angry and
he'd be in trouble his father would
chase him and his father would not chase
him into the
river nearby he'd run into the river and
he'd stay out there and swim until his
dad got cooled off and went away
so he got used to swimming to save his
life
but um we're talking about one river
that he hadn't swarmed yet
and that's the nile and we were
wondering what could be the reason for
that we thought well of course there's
real big crocodiles in the nile yeah
he's always had a support boat that goes
with him and when he was swimming the
amazon he did get attacked by piranhas
at one point
and then a support boat brought the
blood and meat and if piranhas were in
the area
then it looked like they were going to
be a threat they'd be throwing the meat
over the other side to keep them away
from
martin so yeah he's had some interesting
adventures and now he
he does lectures and he talks about you
know keeping the world's rivers clean
because he swam some rivers like the
yangtze in mississippi he said
terribly polluted and it was just very
sad
but the bible talks about well the bible
talks about swimming
said peter when he saw that jesus was on
the shore he jumped in the water
couldn't wait to
for the boat to get all the fish loaded
up and he jumped in the water and swam
to jesus
then there's a prophet that did some
swimming because he ran from god
and he ended up taking a three-day
submarine trip
and that would be i think everyone knows
the prophet jonah
you know it's interesting if you read in
matthew chapter 12
jesus said that no prophet would be get
no
sign would be given to this generation
except the sign of the prophet
jonah for as jonah was three days and
three nights
in the belly of the whale so the son of
man would be three days and three nights
in the heart of the earth
and in many ways joni is a type of
christ
of course jonah was asleep in a boat
during the storm
jesus was asleep in a boat during the
storm
they woke up jonah and said we're
perishing they woke up jesus and said
master were perishing
through waking up jonah the sailors had
peace
through waking up jesus the apostles had
it was through the sacrifice of jonah
that the
ship was saved and through the sacrifice
of christ
that we are saved and then
jesus said as jonah was assigned to the
ninevites he says a little differently
in luke
jonah went a three days journey to
nineveh
entered the city half a day's journey 12
hours
and then preached in 40 days it would be
destroyed
jesus preached three and a half years
and warned that the generation would not
pass away until jerusalem was destroyed
and so you know for one it's three and a
half days and forty days
for jesus it's three and a half years
and 40 years because often a day is a
year in prophecy
so jesus said jonah had many things
that helped us recognize of course jonah
coming out of the whale
that's a resurrection and the
resurrection of christ being one of the
greatest
examples now we have a book that tells
this tells about this
and more maybe some are wondering about
that three days and three nights
they say well it doesn't match up
because you've got you've got
friday night and saturday night but how
do you get three nights out of that
we've got a book that'll answer that
i'm not going to tell you now the book
is called the sign of jonah and we'll be
happy to send this to anyone in north
america
it's yours for the asking all you have
to do is call and ask the number to call
is 800 835
6 that is our resource phone line and
again
just ask for the book called the sign of
jonah and we'll be happy to get that to
you we know we do have those who are
listening outside of north america
we're not able to send you the
literature outside of the continent but
go to the amazing facts
website just amazingfacts.org and you
can actually read that
at our website but here in north america
call and we'll be happy to send you the
book if you have a bible question our
phone line here is open
and we have a few lines that are still
waiting for calls so the number to call
for that is eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven
eight hundred four
six three seventy two ninety seven
and the uh acronym there is god says 800
god says okay we're going to go to chris
listening in florida chris welcome to
the program
yes hello hi you're on chris how you
doing
hi thank you good very good thank you
pastors
i just have an answer to uh i mean i
have a question
uh to help me understand the difference
between
the chosen ones and the elect
yeah the words are actually similar uh
you can read for instance
in the um gospel of matthew
jesus says in matthew 22 14 for many are
called but few are chosen
and simply and if you're called and you
choose to accept the call you are an
elect
elect simply means the ones who have
been
you know they're really accepted
they're god's people because they've
accepted his invitation
and they've come to him and so um
the elector some people think the
elector only like the jews
and i've that's kind of
dispensationalism but anyone who accepts
jesus and follows him is elect where in
fact you read in colossians chapter 3
verse 12
paul is writing principally you have to
gentile believers and he says
therefore as the elect of god put on
holy
conversation beloved and so on so yeah
we find even gentiles referred to as the
elect
it almost seems pastor doug that there
is a choosing that we as individuals do
we choose christ and those who choose
christ
are in one sense elected by christ so
it's almost christ's response to
the personal decision that a person
makes and to be an elect to be elected
by christ
based upon our choice all those kind of
benefits and blessings in store for
those who are
elected by god or chosen by god
absolutely
well thank you chris appreciate that and
you know we we have a book that talks a
little bit about
um it's called assurance and uh that
book on assurance talks a little i think
about
who the elect are yes uh if you like
justification made simple
insurance justification made simple is
the name of the book
and to receive it the phone number is
800-835-6747
and again ask for the book called
assurance justification
made simple we've got noah listening in
illinois no welcome to the program
thank you for having me gene and doug
yeah thanks for calling my question is
um i'm wanting to know how you can share
the 2300 day
uh prophecy which is found in daniel 8
14 in like four minutes
um like under 10 minutes well
yeah all right four let me let me see
how we can do real quick
um if you read in daniel chapter 8 it
talks about a beast
power that would cast down the truth to
the ground
and it says it would practice and
prosper
and then the the angels are speaking and
they say how long
until these things are accomplished and
the angel responds 2
300 days and then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed
now god has a sanctuary in heaven he's
got a sanctuary on earth
the beast's power was corrupting the
truth from the sanctuary in heaven of
our salvation
by christ that christ is there
interceding for us
and the beast power was corrupting god's
sanctuary on earth
the church you are the temple of god
from
the going forth of the commandment to
rebuild jerusalem which you find in
daniel chapter 9
unto that 2 300 days that goes to 1844
that's really when the
the age of the church of laodicea began
and there was a special cleansing of the
sanctuary
a revival in the church that took place
a whole new birth
of god's people um and returning to the
truth
cleansing them from the errors of the
beast and christ
entered into the final phase of his
intercessory work
in heaven i think i did that in two and
a half minutes
so you can that's not the best
explanation but you asked me to do it
quickly
it's not enough that helps at all noah
but um that's a quick summary of it it's
talking about of course the beast
casting the truth to the ground
practicing and prospering
it's defiling the people of god
blaspheming against god
both on earth and in heaven so both in
heaven and on earth
a cleansing began and that started in
1844 when that's done jesus comes
michael stands up and that's the end
well thank you and we do have a lesson
on it
we do i was going to point out the
lesson is called right on time that's
the name of the lesson
and of course we'll send this to anyone
for free it's called right on time
prophetic
appointments revealed and if you'd like
receive that the number is 800-835-6747
and ask for the study guide called right
on time you know one other thing noah
and anyone listening you may not know
amazing facts has a quarterly magazine
called inside report
and i recall our last article is on
the 2300 day prophecy i think it's
called 1844 made simple or something
like that
but it it does explain it i think in a
very easy to understand format
and that is available at the amazing
facts website so you can just look that
up when you go there
thanks for your call now we've got
george listening in um jersey
george welcome to the program new jersey
yes right
good evening how you doing this week all
right doing great
uh this week i have more or less a
history kind of a question
okay i read a lot of writings by the
early church fathers you know i've
gotten some material on the
apostolic fathers i like you know
hearing about what they believed in some
of their doctrines
and in the first three centuries it
appears that they were all pre-or most
of them were all pre-millennial
but i don't see any of them that
believed i guess what what you teach
that the millennium is in heaven not
that that proves or disproves it but
it just seems funny that the early
church if it was taught
you know by the apostles in the early
church that none of the fathers
discussed it
or talked about it so i was just curious
about that if you've ever seen that in
any of the early church literature
well it's a good question you know i i'm
not sure how much the early fathers and
i read some of
uh of what the early fathers have
written now you've got the one
you've got some of the writings of the
fathers that you're talking about the
first 300 years
then you get the reformers which is a
whole other set of writings
uh then there was you know a period of
time where you didn't have a lot of
church writings it was you know
augustine and a few others uh jerome
but um i don't know now i'm wondering
about matthew henry he would be one of
the protestant writers or the puritan
writers
but yeah it's a good question i don't
know i don't know how much they all
wrote about the millennium
so right i don't think they spent a lot
of time writing about where the
millennium was and
and i don't recall reading any i'm sure
it's there but i don't recall reading it
myself
they're not too consistent if i look at
them some of them believe
that the millennium is just going to be
the martyrs reigning
some of them say it's all the christians
so they're not really consistent anyway
you know
well you know you've got that one
chapter in revelation chapter 20 that
talks about it
and so i think that's par probably why
there's some uh
speculation about what that means and
you know we like others do our best to
put the scriptures together and
and say you know what makes the most
sense one reason we have the saints
in heaven during the millennium is
because
we know that jesus said i go to prepare
a place for you
and i will come and receive you that
where i
am ye might come you might be and he
says i will come again so when he comes
he comes to receive us to take us where
he has prepared the places
the other reason is uh in the
popular left behind scheme of prophecy
um they always have the earth populated
right but the bible describes in several
prophecies in isaiah
jeremiah where the earth is completely
vacated
it says the slain of the lord covered
the earth from one end to the other
there is no one to lament mourn or bury
and then you can read in jeremiah 4
verse 23. where it says that uh the
cities were broken down and there was no
man
at the presence of the lord and so it
describes this apocalyptic vision on the
earth after the second coming where no
one's alive
and then ii peter he says the day of the
lord will come in which the elements
melt with fervent heat the earth and the
things in it are burned up
so how life how we could be on earth
during the millennium after that
is hard to comprehend there's you know
two or three witnesses at least
that say the earth is going to be you
know completely
scoured by some judgment for a period of
time
and then ultimately god makes a new
heaven and a new earth
so we take the position that we live and
reign with christ in heaven
because i don't know what christian
wants to reign over the wicked during
for a thousand years i don't want that
and here we've got glorified bodies and
they're still dying it just doesn't
seem to fit yeah all right i appreciate
it i thank you
thanks so much appreciate your call we
do have a lesson on that if you haven't
seen it already yes there might be some
others wondering about the subject of
the thousand years the millennium our
study guide on that topic is called a
thousand years of peace
and of course we'll send this to you for
free the number is 800 835
675 asks for the study guide it's called
a thousand years of peace
we got marie listening in the los
angeles area marie welcome to the
program
hi there good evening gentlemen hi hi
so my question is related to numbers um
i'm aware that
you know there are numbers in the bible
that have significance and i've
downloaded the prophecy handout the
prophecy code handout
which you know says the certain numbers
represent particular things in the bible
and i want to understand the
significance of numbers in the
believer's everyday life
so for example numbers are numbers that
might be mentioned in a dream
or multiples of certain things occurring
in a dream or noticing numbers recurring
around as you're just kind of going
about your day
you know or maybe god even impressing
like a specific dollar about for you to
give to a ministry
so how do we draw the line between god
trying to use numbers to talk to us
and something like numerology well
that's a good question by the way you've
got a good voice for radio and no one's
ever told you that
um you know my wife is my wife she
loves numbers she's always like doing
the the checkbook and she wants
everything to add up and she gets so
excited by it
i on the other hand math was not my
subject
but it is it is clearly obvious that
certain numbers
appear in the bible way beyond
what you would normally expect if they
were just random
numbers like 7 or 3 or 10 40
12. and there seems to be some
consistency in what their meaning is
as far as running into those numbers on
a day-by-day basis i'm not sure god is
trying to talk to us through
you know if if you're invited to a
an event and you're given a seat in the
stadium and you look and your seat is
i won't worry about it you know i would
just sit in it
so there's some numbers are just you
know they're
digits and but i think the numbers in
the bible do have meanings
so i don't know if that answers your
question marie
um well what about the dream part so if
if
if you've had jury i know you know
dreams can be dubious you know ways of
having god speak you have seen certain
uh
sermons that you wrote about how god
speaks to us um
but i'm curious about that like for
example when joseph interpreted certain
dreams and certain things at certain
significance
seven yeah so when do we pay it when do
we pay attention to those things and
when should we actually dismiss them
well you first of all you'd want to know
before you analyze what does the number
mean in a dream you want to know what
does the dream mean
and um you know i think that of course
you had the seven
fat cows seven skinny cows seven fat
grains seven skinny grains and
in daniel with nebuchadnezzar seven
times would pass over him
um but they knew what the meaning of the
dream was and then the numbers took on
relevance so
you've got to either if you're having a
divine dream god is going to give you
the interpretation
or you need a friend that's got that
gift you know something else passed it
it's interesting all of these dreams
that had significance that we read about
in the bible
um especially related to some symbol
there were dreams that were interpreted
by the prophet but they weren't
necessarily the dream that the prophet
had
for example in the case of pharaoh
pharaoh had the dream and then
joseph explained the dream
nebuchadnezzar has the dream
and then daniel explains the dream so
god makes the explanation clear
now of course there's other dreams that
have symbols but it's really a repeat
of daniel chapter two that daniel has so
you know if we have a dream
and we're trying to figure out what the
numbers in our dream might mean
oh i don't know you could go some
interesting places with that
[Laughter]
yeah you know what i would do if i were
you marie is i just say
you know lord if there if i'm supposed
to understand this you got to give me
the interpretation
and just leave it with him by the way
daniel had some dreams and he didn't get
the interpretation until a couple years
later right
so be patient if you're supposed to know
he'll make you know
all right well thank you call yes next
quarter that we have is sandra in new
york sandra welcome to the program
yes thank you for taking my call um my
question is in reference to forgiveness
um we supposed to go we supposed to go
through
steps when we do run
to somebody so if i confess
and then repent and then the
reconciliation
reconciliation supposed to happen but
what happened
if if i don't even know what person
is to reconcile with
that person and that's what forgiveness
well if if you've done something wrong
and you
have hurt somebody and you want to
apologize you do your best to contact
them if you can't
god is not going to hold you accountable
for what you can't do
you know in my testimony i explained
before i was converted i was a thief
i didn't need to be i just kind of did
it for the excitement and i
i broke into homes and stole things well
it was often at night and i was often
on either drunk or inebriated and i
don't even know the address or who owned
the house
so there's you know i told the lord i'm
sorry there's no way i can go back and
contact those people
and so i think you know the holy spirit
will he will impress you if there's
things that you can write if you can
right
certain wrongs you should but there's
some things that you just you can't deal
with and you just have to trust that god
forgives you
so sometimes there's a person you have a
problem with and you want to reconcile
and
you know they don't talk to you so how
do you do it well you write them a
letter maybe
and just if they won't communicate you
put it in god's hands and say
i've done the best i can do lord if
there's anything more
show me otherwise just have peace that
he's forgiven you
so does that help uh
let me just um so how do i know
i know that i know god is loving father
and he
will forgive us if we ask for
forgiveness
but how do i know um i'm in the process
of forgiveness from the
lord how do you know you're
in the process of forgiveness is that
what you're asking
yes will come from
god the bible tells us if you repent of
your sins if you confess your sins to
god
he is faithful and just to forgive us
our sins
and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness and that's
in first john chapter one um
verse nine yeah so
you know you do that and he promises
that if you're repenting of your sins he
will always forgive
if you are sincere tell him you're sorry
and then believe he forgives you
jesus promised all who come to me i will
in no wise cast out
and christ tells us if our brother sins
against us seven times
in a day and seven times come and say
i'm sorry
you should forgive them so if christ is
asking us to do that seven times in a
day
will he do less obviously jesus is going
to be very very patient and merciful
and so i don't think he need to worry
about that sandra and you know we do
have
some material that talks about three
steps to heaven and how you can find
that forgiveness
it's a book and we'll be happy to share
this with anyone the book is called
three steps to heaven
and the phone phone line our resource
phone line is 800-835-6747
and asked for the book called three
steps to heaven we'll be happy to send
it out to anyone who calls
luke is listening for in florida luke
welcome to the program
are you there luke hello hi we've got
about
a minute and a half can we do it
yes i think we can my question is rather
short it pertains to
moses when moses approached pharaoh for
the first time
he said that they were going in the
wilderness for three days and three
nights
but they were leaving egypt for good so
why did moses say that
well you know i think if they had gone
uh directly
a three-day journey they could have come
to the first place of sacrifice
he wanted to get a three days distance
from egypt because it was a great
abomination to the egyptians
to offer animal sacrifice and and
matter of fact when the israelites moved
into egypt
it says every shepherd was an
abomination to the egyptians
so i don't know that that he was saying
their journey would be done in three
days
i don't even know if moses knew exactly
where they were going well i take it
back god said they'll come to this
mountain and worship me he did tell him
that
but i think mount sinai was further than
three days
so i think maybe the first three days
was where they could
pause and sacrifice
so you're there yeah i'm here
so what he was just saying was we need
to go three days into the world and it's
just sacrificed to our god
basically yeah you know it is an
interesting question because you're
right
if if uh pharaoh had said okay i'll let
you go three days make sure and come
back
moses would have said not on your life
we're not coming back
he did say let my people go but it
sounded like he said let my people go
that they may
serve me and um
yeah i think it was they wanted to get
three days out of egypt so that they
could
offer sacrifice i think it may have been
a three-day journey to even get across
the red sea
and you know a day's journey into the
wilderness
so good question luke i'm kind of
dancing around because i'm not exactly
sure
yeah i've heard that question before and
we're wondering maybe
you know moses was under the impression
that if he could get israel out of egypt
for three days at least
then perhaps god could do a greater work
of deliverance
that's one explanation as to why he just
says three days of course he knew
pharaoh wouldn't do it
and of course it was after three days
jesus rose and so the end the exodus is
a type
of the plan of salvation so
often great things happened after three
days in the bible
anyway thank you luke for your question
and i hope that helps a little bit
friends this music does not mean we're
going away we're just gonna catch our
breath
we'll be back in just a moment
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
in six days god created the heavens and
the earth
for thousands of years man has
worshipped god on the seventh day of the
week
now each week millions of people worship
on the first day
what happened why did god create a day
of rest
does it really matter what day we
worship who is behind this great shift
discover the truth behind god's law and
how it was changed
visit sabbathtruth.com
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
did you know that noah was present at
the birth of abraham
ok maybe he wasn't in the room but he
was alive and probably telling stories
about his floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of revelation
biblehistory.com is a free resource
where you can explore
major bible events and characters
enhance your knowledge of the bible
and draw closer to god's word go deeper
visit biblehistory.com
what if you could know the future
what would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past alexander
the great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy 150 years in
advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
doug batchelor
explores the most striking bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit
kingdomsandtime.com
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god
and his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life
today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live we are back listening
friends this is bible answers live and
if you have a bible question we invite
you to give us a call
when the number is 800-463-7297
that's 800 god says and we are also
streaming this broadcast
on facebook and that would be at the
amazing facts
facebook page or the doug batchelor
facebook page
and i am doug batcheller and i'm john
ross we've got uh roland listening in
tennessee
roland welcome to the program
hi roland you're on the air thank you
pastor
thank you pastor doug thank you pastor
sean i i have a question here
i read in daniel chapter 2
that the last of the
empires would be a divided one in verse
41 it says the kingdom shall be divided
and then on verse 43 i read that
they shall not cleave to one another
speaking of
these guys coming together and then you
know the stone comes and it
finishes that uh prophetic vision but
then
on revelation 13 i see
on verse 3 that the whole the whole
world wanders
after the beast so i see a union there
and i'm confused about the disunity in
one verse and the unity on the other
verse and they're both
uh times of the end here right
yeah good question your thoughts were i
think the key there
is that uh there will never be as daniel
foretold
a one world kingdom politically
um and you know several have tried
everyone from
charlemagne kaiser wilhelm hitler
mussolini
napoleon they all tried to sort of
reunite the
fractured roman empire that broke into
ten parts
but there will be one world religion
and you know you you're going to end up
having
a confederacy of a number of nations
that are
going to come together and they're going
to be agreeing on how to worship
but they're not going to weld together
politically that will never happen again
you're never going to have the kind of a
mighty empire that you had
under alexander the great or
nebuchadnezzar
or caesar or
cyrus the persian but
you will have a very strong religious
union that's going to happen and they're
going to compel worship
they're not compelling taxes
great thank you you clarify my all right
hey thank you so much appreciate your
question
all right we have uh i believe it's
donna listening from
connecticut or dana dana welcome to the
program
norwalk hi you're on hello pastor
bachelor
and i forgot his name oh what's his name
that's okay thingamajig
pastor okay
um i have a question about what are your
thoughts about the
mandatory cover 19 vaccine
well i've had several people someone
asked me that question during the zoom
worship i was doing yesterday i would be
very uncomfortable
with that just because for one thing i
don't like any
being an american i don't like any
government agency telling me
what i have to do with my body that i
think is unconstitutional
but fortunately if i can believe the
news
the news did report on friday that the
president-elect
said that they are not going to make the
vaccine mandatory so
that i think caused a lot of people to
breathe a collective sigh of relief
so you know hypothetically i could talk
about what i would do
i would not be comfortable with the
government you know mandating you've got
to
do something like that i can understand
why they would you know
i don't agree with them mandating that
parents have to get their children
inoculated but i understand why they
you know there's arguments for and
against that i do think that there's
value in certain vaccines through
history
there's no question that you know things
like polio
and diphtheria and other terrible
diseases were arrested
because of good vaccines but you know
from what i
understand and i'm only getting you know
superficial information
um the the vaccines that are being
developed now because they accelerated
the process
that they actually got into some dna
altering technology and folks are saying
we're wondering what the long-term
effects of this are
it is true there have been drugs that at
first everyone thought they were great a
few years later they found out there
were side effects
so you always you want to be as natural
as possible in my
opinion um but i
i'm not a doctor so don't follow my
medical advice
i got to say that because people always
sue
all right hey thanks so much donna we
appreciate your question hurry
good call listening in oregon carl
welcome to the program
yes thank you can you hear me loud and
clear
all right how you doing pastor doug
everything okay over there yeah we're
doing much better than we deserve
that's great one of my questions well
it's it's more of a
i need a confirmation from you guys you
know god's law
is eternal that's what the bible says
you know it's eternal so that means
the ten commandments have existed way
before
um earth was created and even holy
angels
so why would there be a ten commandments
before anything was created
where you know let's say angels were
already created
but the ten commandments say thou shalt
not kill they cannot kill each other or
they
thou shalt not covet your each other's
wives
they couldn't marry so even when earth
was created
adam couldn't kill eve even even if he
wanted to so
i just need confirmation that the ten
commandments didn't come into play
until you know moses
but i mean it was some kind of moral law
because
yeah you know god knew it was a sin that
came
till right well let's talk about let's
talk about that for just a second
the verses in the bible that say god's
law is eternal from everlasting
everlasting
there's always been law as long as there
has been god because keep in mind
the ten commandments are summarized in
one word
love god is love the first four
commandments to deal with a love for
your fellow
love for a god the last six deal with
love for our fellow man first four
commandments deals with the vertical
love relationship
the last six commandments it's the
horizontal love relationship
so the laws that are governing
uh by love have always existed because
god is
love so it was always wrong for an angel
or any to be dishonest or to take
innocent life
so forth the ten commandments are a
a more defined expression that may
appeal more to our world
but they're still summed up in god's
eternal law of love
so i don't know if that makes sense but
yeah the ten commandments of
i think the principle of the ten
commandments the law of love has always
been there
uh it you know angels may not have
worried about uh taking
another angel's wife because angels
don't marry so some of those laws if i
love my neighbor
i will not violate covenants he's made
of marriage
and so out of love for our neighbor
those laws really always existed because
love has always been the law
you know has to take another law just to
illustrate that point the principle of
love is throughout
all eternity but the sabbath we know
that the sabbath was made
um after six days of creation god rested
on the seventh day he blessed it he
sanctified it
so the fourth commandment that talks
about the sabbath seems to be in
particular given
for those created on earth now that
doesn't mean the angels don't have a
special
day when they gather to worship but as
far as the earth is is concerned
the fourth commandment is relating to us
based upon time and place we're here god
made us and it reminds us of his
creative power
you know we do have a lesson talking
about the ten commandments it's called
written in stone
and uh it covers some of these questions
you have carl as well as anyone else
listening
about the ten commandments so did they
only show up
when um god gave them to moses to give
the children of israel or did they exist
before that
you only enjoy reading this if you'd
like to receive the study guide the
number to call is 800-835-6747
and asked for the study guide called
written in stone
we've got richard listening in canada
richard welcome to the program
hello thank you for having me on thank
you your question tonight well
my my question is
are christians in the earth
when the seven last plagues begin to
fall and
my reference for this question is
mainly revelation chapter 15. it seems
to
indicate that the the redeemed are
on the sea of glass in heaven when the
when the seven at when the seven angels
go and pour out the seven last plays
upon the earth
and you
you uh teach and and i i
i i believe that christians will go
through
a great tribulation in the future but
it seems to be indicating here that they
seem to be out of the world
when the wrath of god falls right
well uh when the plagues fall when it
talks in revelation 15 it says i saw
something like a sea of glass
and on that it says they've got those
who have gotten the victory sitting
on the throne i think the beginning it's
reminding us before the plagues fall
that the redeemed are going to be uh
they're going to make it through the
plagues you know this is a common
feature that we see in revelation for
example revelation chapter 14
describes the 144 000 standing with the
lamb on mount zion
and then it reads about the three angels
messages which is god's last warning
message to the world and then the second
coming
so it's not uncommon to first get a
broad picture
showing the redeemed those who have
overcome and then it explains further
what they overcame
so just like the hundred and forty four
thousand they are described as being
victorious
and then it explains how they became
victorious because of the blood of the
land they kept the commandments and so
on
and then if you get to chapter 15 you're
talking about the seven last plagues
and you have this group of people
described standing on the sea of glass
those are the ones who have overcome
they've got the seal of god they've been
protected during this time
of the plagues being poured out another
way that we know this is
the seventh plague talks about this
great earthquake
and a voice from the throne saying it
he's done according to revelation
chapter six
that is the earthquake that takes place
at the second coming of christ when the
graves are opened up and the dating
christ rise false
so you know revelation is not written in
a chronological order and this confuses
people you have the seven churches the
seven seals
seven trumpets it's sort of repeat and
enlarge
yeah so you can't strictly go on a
chronological order when you look at
revelation
you know and one other thought on that
richard is
you're wanting to know will the redeemed
be in the world during the seven last
plagues
were god's people in egypt when the
plagues fell on
egypt and of course the answer is yes
and he preserved them through the
plagues now the first three plagues they
kind of
they suffered with the egyptians but god
protected him through the last
seven of the ten plagues that fell on
egypt
so i'm not at all worried about the
seven last plagues
i believe that you know god can save us
it says
neither will any plague come now you're
dwelling only with your eyes will you
see and behold the destruction so you're
there
but it doesn't affect you he'll preserve
us that's psalm 91 by the way
so hope that helps a little and we
appreciate your question richard thank
you
all right again richard you might enjoy
that magazine we mentioned
earlier talking about a thousand years
of peace talking about the
millennium and what happens just before
that and afterwards if you'd like to
receive that the number again
is 800-835-6747
after the study guide a thousand years
of peace we have
damon listening from oklahoma city damon
welcome to the program you on the air
yes hello can you hear me yes
loud hey hey how you guys doing this
evening
good evening thank you for calling thank
you
i had a question about who
was it um with who was who was it
with the adam and eve um
when they sinned was it god the father
or was it jesus
um because i know that i'm god the
father could be there
before they sin but after they sin um
how could god the father be in the
presence of sin
and i don't think it was jesus because
he wasn't
he hadn't came to earth so i was kind of
want to know who was it with them
because i know i said he walked in the
midst of the garden and things like that
yeah so yeah that's what i was wondering
well good question i personally think
that
it was jesus because christ is the one
all things were made were made by him
and
even the new testament tells us that god
commanded creation
unto the son and he's committed judgment
unto the son
and it was jesus who i think explained
to adam and eve the plan of salvation
after they sinned
so jesus also said no man has seen the
father
at any time so if no man has seen the
father and if adam was a man
well that would mean that um must have
been christ
god the son is the one who adam saw so
you're talking about christ in his
pre-incarnation state
um yeah so jesus you know even jesus
said abraham longed to see my day and he
saw it
and that was before christ was incarnate
does that help at all damon
uh yeah that's a good that was a great
answer i was just i was
always wondering but thank you guys for
that all right thanks so much appreciate
your question
zachary's listening in canada zachary
are you on the air
hi good night evening uh
my question is why wasn't jesus married
and
isn't what does the bible say about
masturbation
okay two different questions but i think
there may even be a connection there
uh we would assume that you know god
created jesus as a normal
he was born incarnate as a normal
healthy man who would have all of the
desires
and the bible tells us that jesus was
tempted in all points as we
are yet without sin now if jesus said
if a man and i'm sure it's true of a
woman also looks on the opposite s
sex and lusts in their heart they can be
committing adultery in their heart
and typically when a person is engaged
in that activity
they are lusting in their heart
and so that is described in the bible as
an impure action uh you know i don't
believe it's the unpardonable sin
but um yeah god is calling us to purity
into holiness
and so and i think jesus he was faithful
in every area
why was jesus not married well because
in a sense christ was married to the
church
the bible says husbands love your wives
even as christ
loved the church and gave himself for i
know that
people in hollywood just find it so hard
to believe that jesus lived a pure life
they keep insisting that well he must
have he must have had an affair with
mary and some are so sacrilegious as to
say well
he and the apostles had something
happening and it just makes me cringe
when i
i hear that and the reason they come up
with those theories is they think
how is it possible for a man
to live a sexually pure life and
they just can't because they don't they
assume no one else can
and so they try to bring jesus down to
their level
but i think the bible's pretty clear
that he did no sin
[Music]
all right well thank you for your call
zach we've got jennifer
in sacramento jennifer welcome to the
program
thank you so much good evening to you
both good evening
god bless you both and i thank you so
much i used to live in roseville and i
used to pass by
your headquarters there your old
building oh great well you have to come
visit the new one if they ever open
society again
right um yeah but since then i have
actually
migrated to el paso texas so my phone
number i haven't changed yet so it's
still sacramento but
i am currently in el paso texas but can
you tell me i'm just really curious what
is the temperature down there right now
um it is it's actually kind of cool
right now it's like in the six
in the 50s and 60s oh it's all right
we're like 38
i think that's what you're doing good
yeah i've been through el paso many
times this nice place
all right and your question yes i have a
two-part question
the first one is um my mom who was
cremated she was when she passed she she
was cremated
um and part of her ashes ended up
in the pangasinan sea which is in the
philippines okay
and um the other part my brother kept in
an urn
which i believe is still with him and um
when we when we get caught up in the air
with jesus and the dead
will rise first will my mom go
um because she wasn't buried
but she you know she was cremated i
wonder will she
obtain a new body even though it's like
she's kind of fish food
too at the same time yeah no that won't
be a problem
keep in mind god is not resurrecting us
using old material
the bible says flesh and blood cannot
inherit the kingdom of heaven
uh those things are spiritual are are
going to be spiritually
so um you know there's a lot of faithful
christians through the ages that have
been
and they've either died at sea and then
of course their remains get scattered
everywhere when they're buried at sea
or they are burned at the stake and they
scatter their ashes and
some of the church fathers that are the
persecutors were thinking
all we have to do is um burn them and
scatter their ashes and that's going to
somehow keep god from resurrecting them
but
nothing could be further from the truth
and how god does it
is still a mystery but i have no doubt
at all that he's going to be able to
reassemble people
actually he's not using the old parts
but he'll be raising them up he's got
the personal information of who your
mother is on his hard drive and he will
download that into a glorified new body
now whether that is going to show up
first in the philippines or in north
america i can't tell you
you know pastor reminds me and we'll get
back to your second question jennifer
um it was wycliffe i believe that was
bare he died
he was buried but then the church got so
upset with him
sometime later they dug up his bones
burned his bones kind of ground them to
ash
whatever was left took the ashes through
it in a river and the river took the
ashes to the sea
they were trying to make sure that god
couldn't resurrect him but of course
god's not um handicapped by that he can
resurrect people yeah that's
it's silly for a man to think that we
could do something to prevent god if he
can make adam from dirt
yep then and make him in his own image
and he can resurrect people
good question thank you hope that helps
a little jennifer did you have another
part of your question
i did um the other part is about my
children
i have a two-year-old and a
four-year-old their names are moses
and elijah and they
both have autism and i was wondering
um i'm teaching them you know i'm
wondering about when
you know also when we pass away or you
know i believe that jesus is coming real
soon
that's my personal belief yes and um
and i'm i'm hoping and praying and i
don't know if i have to baptize my
children but i i'm unable to because the
churches around here are actually
closed by the pandemic so i'm wondering
are they okay uh will they be
raptured up i mean maybe by that time
they might be in their teams they might
be well you know it
means i don't know yeah the lord judges
us based upon our understanding and the
reason that young children
are not responsible there before they
reach the age of accountability
is because they're understanding
comprehension their ability to respond
to the gospel
it's just not there when their babies
are very young as they get older
and their minds mature and they
understand the gospel and they respond
they're accountable for knowing the
difference between right and wrong and
having
the god given power to make choices you
know i don't know
what the exact degree of challenges with
your children but
you can just trust that god is going to
be fair there are some people that may
be 50 years old but god's going to judge
them like they're
six years old because you know they just
never were able to
psychologically develop to that age of
accountability
and so you don't need to worry about
that if that's the case
and you know just trust that god is a
merciful god
on the other hand if they've got you
know a light case of that and they're
able to do studies and understand the
gospel and
and be baptized i know some some
children because of autism they're
terrified of getting their heads
underwater
and i don't think god's gonna you know
god doesn't want parents to put them
through something traumatic
and make them think it's gonna be
spiritually a blessing
so uh just know god is a patient loving
just god
okay and jennifer and and you
you continue to hold your children up in
prayer be a good example and trust
they'll be in the kingdom
all right thank you for your call we've
got jimmy listening in puerto rico jimmy
welcome to the program
how's it going thank you so much for
taking my call good evening evening so i
have a question i
i do believe that we will be in heaven
for a thousand years
um but i've heard of the millennial
theory
where the earth we will be here for six
thousand years and i know
it's just a theory but i was wondering
um
how biblical that theory is
well you know it remains let me just
explain for our friends that are
listening jimmy
there's a a teaching that it goes back
hundreds of years and
several reformers believed it that
because
it tells us in both psalms and in second
peter
chapter 3 a day where the lord is like a
thousand years
and since the creation when you add up
the ages in the bible goes back
approximately 6 000 years
and then we're going to spend a thousand
years living and reigning with god in
heaven
they say well you know when when our
world gets to that 6 000 year
period that uh you know jesus will come
and um then we'll have like a thousand
year sabbath so it's like
the 7 000 year theory um
you know i know a lot of people when
when the world in 1996 it was six
thousand years from the birth of christ
they were sure that jesus was going to
come and then folks started saying well
maybe it's not the birth of christ maybe
it's going to be
6 000 years from the crucifixion
and then another group is saying no it's
going to be 6 000 years from the baptism
of jesus
and i think we need to be very careful
about setting dates because
for one thing it could be sooner than we
think because the bible says except
those days be short and no flesh would
be saved
and it could be later than we think
because ii peter also says
god is long suffering to us not willing
that things should perish
i know that jesus said in such an hours
you think not the son of man comes so it
sounds like everyone's going to be a
little bit surprised
but then again he tells us that they
should not overtake you as a thief
so we should be looking at the signs
anyway
um so that's what the 6 000 year theory
is and
you know i i i'd go back and do a little
follow-up with you
jimmy but we're looking now we've got
about a minute left
before we have to cut to our
announcements and maybe pastor ross we
should just be
uh letting our friends know that in
amazing facts we're going to be
uplinging a special new year's program
friday night on january one we're going
to be doing something that
is called the resolution like resolution
everyone's making new year's resolutions
for
friday sabbath morning saturday evening
we're going to be talking about
beginning the new year in the word and
you'll see more information about this
at the amazing facts website
we'd encourage you to join us in that
new year's resolution
to just begin your new year in the word
of god and get grounded in his word
also keep in mind that so much of what
we talk about during this broadcast
you can listen to again and you can look
at all the other material many of the
books that we offer
amazingfacts.org that website
has got just layers and layers of
biblical information
to keep you close to the lord and help
you be a better witness for him
god bless friends we're going to study
his word together again next week
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you
understand your bible even better than
before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
[Music]
an international pandemic killing
thousands
riots ripping communities apart a global
economic implosion many are wondering
is this the end of the world few
question the military
economic and technological might of the
united states
so if we really are facing the last days
if these worldwide catastrophes are
really harbingers of the end
shouldn't we expect the united states to
play a key role
in the final events of bible prophecy
the book of revelation provides
unmistakable clues and to help you
understand them
amazing facts is releasing america in
bible prophecy
it's going to take you step by step in
identifying the global forces at work
in these last days you might be
surprised what the bible really says
you owe it to yourself to find out so
get yourself a copy
of america in bible prophecy for
life-changing christian resources visit
afbookstore.com
would you like to know god's plan for
our troubled world and solutions for
your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned and updated
amazing facts 27 bible study guides
provide straightforward bible-based
answers that are enlightening
encouraging and easy to understand
giving you real relevant bible answers
to questions like
how can i have healthier relationships
when will jesus come
and much more order yours today by
visiting afbookstore.com
or by calling 800-538-7275
did you know amazing facts has a free
bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons to aid in your study of
god's word
sign up today for this free bible study
course by calling 1-844-215-7000 that's
1-844-215
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800-835-6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org